You are not going to believe this or you
are, and maybe that's really the problem,
that it's very believable. Yesterday, Joe Biden's
administration made a major announcement on
vaccination. This is not the surprising part. I'll
get you to the surprising part in a moment. The
administration of Joe Biden has been delivering
hugely when it comes to coronaviruses vaccines.
Joe Biden initially said the goal is 100 million
doses in 100 days. Now, at the time, I said
we're sort of like already on track for eighty
nine million. So it's not super ambitious. But
then he doubled that goal to 200 million doses
in 100 days. Joe Biden then moved up the full
eligibility date to May 1st. And yesterday, Joe
Biden moved it up even further, announcing that
as of now, on April 19th, there will be full
adult eligibility for coronavirus vaccines
in all 50 states, regardless of age, regardless of
occupation, regardless of health status. And that
is a really big deal. We are now giving doses to
roughly one percent of the entire U.S. population
every single day, about three million doses
per day. Huge announcement, incredible success
with the accelerating vaccination program under
this administration. And when Joe Biden finishes
telling the United States about this great news,
Peter Doocy from Fox News. When Joe Biden finishes
up, gets up and yells at Joe Biden, should the
Masters golf tournament be moved out of Georgia?
What yeah, that's what Peter Doocy urgently
yelled at Joe Biden after a momentous
announcement with regard to vaccines and Joe
Biden handles it well, we're going to look at it.
And Joe Biden's approach has been the right one to
this boycott stuff from the beginning. Joe Biden
says companies should do what they want to do. I
support businesses deciding what's best for them.
It's almost like a conservative position, but
the voter suppression has to stop. Check out
the exchange. And remember, Biden's event was
about vaccines. Biden wasn't scheduled to take
questions. Biden is under no obligation to answer
stupid questions. Yelled at him by Peter Doocy,
but he does anyway. Despite the right
narrative, the right wing narrative being
that Joe Biden won't answer any questions
from reporters. Take a look at this.
The Masters golf tournament
should be moved out of Georgia.
I think that's up to the Masters. Look.
You know, it is reassuring to see that
for profit operations and
businesses are speaking up about how
these new Jim Crow laws are just antithetical
to who we are. There's another side to
the other side of it, too, is when they, in
fact, move out of Georgia. The people who
need the help the most people are making
hourly wages sometimes get hurt the most.
I think it's a very tough decision for a
corporation to make or group to make. But
I respect them when they make that judgment and
I support whatever judgment they make. But it's
the best way to deal with this is for Georgia and
other states to smarten up. Stop it. Stop smoking.
You know, in a sense, conservatives
should love that answer. These are
for profit businesses making, you know,
the the apple of the Republican eye is
the for profit business and it's a for profit
business making the decision they want to make
and then dealing with whatever consequences come
of it, period. Another thing Joe Biden does well
there is once he gets out of the way, the reminder
that these are private businesses deciding
things for themselves. He gets back to the core
issue. And I think that this is something that
we should always be doing when this issue comes
up, which is the core issue is Republicans didn't
get enough votes in 2020. Or what I mean by that
is they didn't suppress enough votes in 2020.
In particular, this happened in Georgia. Joe
Biden took Georgia first Democratic presidential
candidate and a long time to win Georgia. Two
Democratic challengers unseated two Republican
incumbent senators in Georgia. And so Republicans
are now trying to suppress the vote even more.
We have more than 250 voter suppression bills
across the country. That's also happening
in Georgia. And Joe Biden puts the focus on
that. That's exactly what he should be doing.
One bonus clip here, Joe Biden, after the same
event, is asked if he's spoken or met with
Federal Reserve Chairman Jay Powell. Jerome
Powell, he goes by Jay and Joe Biden says no.
And he explains, you know, the Fed is supposed to
be independent, like understanding the genesis of
these organizations. Biden doesn't want to get
too involved with the Fed and certainly isn't
going to be telling them what to do the way
that Donald Trump did. Take a listen to this
last question, Mr. President. You from going
to the Federal Reserve chairman, Jay Powell,
here? I have not said why the.
I am not. Look, I think the Federal
Reserve is an independent operation and starting
off my presidency, I want to be real clear
and I'm not going to do the kinds of things
that have been done in the last administration
either talking to the attorney general about
who is going to prosecute or not prosecute
and under what circumstances, or the Fed telling
them what they should and shouldn't do, even
though that wouldn't be the basis upon which I'd
be talking to them. So I've been very fastidious
about not talking to them, but I do talked
to the secretary of Treasury. Thank you. Over
and over. Mr. President, you mentioned 500.
I was pleasantly surprised know. But I've
had my criticisms of Joe Biden
so far. I've had my praise.
Biden wasn't even scheduled to take questions.
He wasn't expected to take questions. He did.
And he made some principles very clear in ways
that I don't think reporters particularly liked
because it gave them nothing. And Joe Biden, he
almost seems to enjoy toying with Peter Doocy,
who, by the way, I mean, if back when you had
reporters yelling questions that Trump like that,
you had Fox and others saying it's disrespectful,
it's disrespectful to yell out questions like that
to the president, that they seem thrilled. The
right does with Peter do these questions and Joe
Biden handling them very well. I want to do one
more Peter Doocy segment next, because it actually
relates to a really important discussion about
Georgia, Colorado, the all star game, and more.